hi guys I will cut right to the point I
am taking a hiatus for about a month and
the reason is I'm not very happy with
the videos that I've been making and
that's not to say that I'm burnt out on
making videos I totally the opposite
I'm actually more eager than I ever have
been to make videos and that's kind of
part of the problem I love making videos
I I'm more than happy to work non-stop
on something that I'm proud of I'm a
workaholic I'll work every day bro I I
don't take weekends I don't take
vacations and I know this may sound
strange to you guys because like the
schedule is super wonky so if I'm
working non-stop and wire videos so
inconsistent I'm basically completely
absent from social media and in a weird
way it could seem like I'm doing nothing
at all when in fact I'm trying to do
more than ever at making the videos
better or making me more satisfied with
the videos that I'm doing but without a
way to exceed my own expectations and
what I'm doing and what I'm posting in
the videos that I'm making I don't feel
like I'm ever improving so then on and
on it goes that I keep adding more and
more effort into what I do and then it's
this cyclical thing where I go oh it's
not enough or oh I need to work harder
at this or or or I need to work better
this or improve this one thing and yet
this kind of cycle has been going on for
about a year now where I continually am
unhappy with the videos that I make I
try to solve the problem with brute
force effort rather than creativity in
the end I just don't want to settle on
the videos that I'm really proud of and
really excited for and really happy with
and the videos that make me laugh that I
make you know I don't want those to be
the exception to the rule I want those
to be the rule now this doesn't mean
that I'm gonna be disappearing a hiatus
doesn't mean that I'm taking a vacation
I just told you I don't do that I'm
actually gonna be filming and planning
and writing and collaborating every
single day leading up to this and it
also doesn't mean that I'm going to be
completely vacant on content like I'm
probably gonna be more like more active
on social media than ever over the exact
few weeks just because I will be goofing
with you guys I'll be talking with you
guys I hope you're trying to get
feedback from you guys I will be like in
tune with the community again which is
something that I've ever
much miss and also there will still be
content during this time not a lot but
there will still be content we have our
charity livestream on the 30th of
November we're doing we still have the
big project that is coming out and I
will tell you a release date just to
give you something to look forward to
that is coming out Friday the 13th of
October and it's gonna be pretty cool so
you can look forward to that and
obviously we're still doing the tour
like the tour is definitely still
happening and I can't wait to do that I
can't wait to be performing for you guys
with my friends and even then we're
gonna be out there and we're gonna be
filming cool stuff while we're doing it
and I'm gonna be talking with Bob and
Wade and Tyler and Ethan I'm gonna be
talking with all those guys about like
what videos can really like really make
me passionate about it you know what
what videos can I really burn for it
what videos can I really like really
strive to improve upon him and what
videos can I like surprise you guys cuz
I know I can make really cool stuff it's
just that you know my focus hasn't been
able to be 100% dedicated like I'm an
obsessive person I want to go to bed
with a smile on my face knowing that
what I made is something that people can
remember something that people will
cherish something that I'll cherish you
know and that's that's what's important
so anyway to recap I'm going on hiatus
I'll be back October 23rd is when I'm
aiming to go back that is the date set
in stone so you guys can count on seeing
the new stuff starting to roll out on
the 23rd of October and still doing the
charity livestream still doing the big
projects still doing the tour and it
should be a lot of fun so thank you guys
so much for understanding if you are
upset about this please record yourself
screaming and panicking in the streets
and post it all over social media as is
the usual markiplier crisis response so
thank you all so much for watching and
it may take a bit but I promise wink
wonk I will see you in the next video
bye